as a kid my mom didn't really believe in  Western medicine so whenever I got sick  or if anything happened go to one of  those herb shops right where there's  [ __ ] like 6 000 drawers this is the  way they diagnose you  like oh your liver man no good oh your  kidney goes no good I'm pretty sure  that's my heart but my medication would  be like this butcher paper full of like  wasps [ __ ] dried ants with these  [ __ ] berries and [ __ ] I'm like you  know your kid just like what the [ __ ] is  this I have to eat this the scale is so  uh you don't go like this and it's like  oh it's pretty accurate the guy is  holding it himself before he even like  stabilizes it okay good then he eyeballs  it and he goes fake ass witch right yeah  to take this one and puts it over there  pretty sure it all uneven it and I go  home and Mom gotta Brew it did it work  though I don't even think I was sick to  begin with